[Music]  you look very dapper as always is your  girlfriend helped you pick out your  suits and what you're gonna wear no give  each other advice no I mean won't she'll  ask me you know normally what collar I'm  wear what is the most romantic thing  you've ever done um you know I subscribe  to like not like necessarily giving a  big Christmas present at Christmas a big  birthday present or doing any giant  outlandish romantic gestures I try to  keep it consistent like small amount of  romance all the time that's my strategy  what is small amount of romance it what  does that entail well you know like  cooking like going on buying favorite  groceries and cooking the meal in milady  life so I'm an excellent cook it's the  thing that I enjoy doing the most in my  free time so yeah well if I'm cooking  for my girlfriend she loves pasta so I  normally if I'm like gonna spoil her  I'll go out and make some pasta  [Music]  you